so what today I want to tell you are
basically two things about the Russia
probe and the left I hinted at talking
about this in the first segment first of
all I believe that the left is slowly
converging on agreement about the Trump
Russia probe and some of the really
toxic disagreements are starting to fade
away and that's a really really good
thing the second thing I want to mention
is that the left had damn well better
figure out how not to be divided on the
Russia probe in a way that is toxic and
destructive because it's going to crush
us in 2020 to the extent that the
internal left-wing disagreements remain
as prominent on this issue of the Russia
investigation a really big deal has been
made over the last several weeks since
the bar letter about the Russia probe
came out about who was right who was
wrong who needs to apologize who's
exonerated and who can go on a victory
tour around the United States or around
Twitter as it has actually been in
reality I expected the right to do this
but even the left has been engaged with
it people demanding apologies of people
claiming exonerations I don't want to
minimize how bad it has been because it
has been really really bad but what I
want to point out is that I've seen
slowly but surely the good-faith left
which is most of it I want to be clear
converge on a pretty coherent and
unified story on the Russia probe I'm
going to give you one example okay Glenn
Greenwald
is a journalist he's a prominent Russia
skeptic he's been very critical of many
elements of coverage of the Russia probe
and he seems to have in just two weeks
changed his tune on the issue of whether
there is any evidence of collusion from
the Russia investigation take a look at
these clips first ones from Democracy
Now
second one is from the majority report
with sam cedar pay really close
attention to what he says here two weeks
ago on Democracy Now right when the bar
letter came out look at what Greg Len
Greenwald said about evidence the media
got the story wrong they obsessed on
this for three years and though all this
time there was no evidence for it it was
just a conspiracy
Spira see theory rachel maddow the most
influential liberal TV host in the
country every single night mislead
millions of liberal that is really
really clear no evidence no evidence and
by the way though two weeks go by and we
start to realize oh you know the bar
letter is a public relations document
the report the the the bar letter is
totally politicized no evidence is
probably a little a little bit overboard
compared to what we actually know given
that we haven't even seen the molar
report yet and sam cedar interviewed
glenn greenwald late last week on the
majority report and look at glenn
greenwald's very different answer about
no evidence you know i know i noticed
like when you talk about the the muller
investigation you're not saying there's
no evidence that he found no evidence
anymore all you because all we know from
the bar assessment is that to the extent
that he found any evidence and maybe he
didn't find any but he could have also
found some right but just not enough for
an indictment you agree with that so so
we're not gonna know until them all our
reporters release what exactly rob moore
said right but so but i do think it's
important to note the following in
general prosecutors have a very narrow
mandate right okay so that's very
clearly not what he said on democracy
now on democracy now he was shouting
there was never any evidence and there's
no evidence here when he's confronted
about it by sam he goes into
explanations of prosecutorial mandates
and thresholds of evidence required for
indictment and then here's another
moment from later in the same interview
with sam precise i mean nobody would say
no evidence right like the trump tower
meeting is evidence right so the
question is is it like compelling
evidence is it convincing so yeah yeah I
agree with you I agree I feel like there
were people who are getting out in front
of their skis on this stuff and you may
be right about what establish means in
that instance we're not going to know
until we see the the report and i hope
we we do end up seeing that so glenn now
agrees with Sam or
sort of sounds like he agrees with Sam
about this issue of evidence but he was
saying something very different two
weeks ago and he was saying it very
loudly on Democracy Now
he went from angrily proclaiming that
there's no evidence and there never was
it's a sort of equivocating and saying
well what do we mean by evidence
evidence that reaches which which
standard which is a very significant
change now I want to be clear I'm not
criticizing glenn greenwald here i'm
praising glenn greenwald we shouldn't
shame glenn greenwald because he went
from saying no evidence to well there's
evidence what does the evidence mean
what threshold does the evidence reach
and let's wait and see what Muller says
he was very emotional in the Democracy
Now interview we've all been emotional
about this but he revised his point of
view which is great and I believe that
at this point in time the left is
basically 90% in agreement on the Russia
probe let me put up on the screen what I
think almost the entire left agrees with
and what we disagree on the left most of
the agrees that Trump is likely criminal
when it comes to financial crimes and
corruption that Trump was never likely
to be indicted for personally colluding
with Russia that the Muller probe was
legal that the molar probe should have
taken place that corporate media
sensationalized the story that William
bar has an undeniable history of
covering up presidential crimes that the
bar letter is a political document not a
summary of the probe that the full molar
report must be released that Trump
colluded was never a good 2018 or 2020
strategy for Democrats and that waiting
around for Donald Trump to be removed by
either impeachment or a 25th amendment
removal is a terrible strategy for
Democrats I can boil down the less
disagreements on Russia not
hyperbolically not on tone and language
but on the facts to what was the right
amount of coverage of the probe as it
was going on there are disagreements
about that and what was the correct
context within which the probe should
have been covered I think 90% of the
left is converging on that set of
beliefs agreements and disagreements and
that's a good thing and everybody who is
participating in getting United on what
didn't happen is helping the left for
2020 and if we can't get past this it's
not going to be good in the next
election agree with me disagree let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show we
all know and have talked about how
mentally exhausting it has become to
keep up with the news lately because of
everything that's been going on over the
last few years which is why I'm so happy
to tell you about one of today's
sponsors simple habit and it's an app
that gives you instant access to
thousands of really good five-minute
guided meditations and I encourage you
to try it for free by going to simple
habit dot-com slash Pakman each
meditation on simple habit was designed
for a specific purpose like waking up
falling asleep dealing with stress
getting focused for work that you have
to do
I've really enjoyed integrating simple
habit into my day especially because
they just make it so easy
each meditation is just five minutes
long different meditations are catered
for whatever you're doing whether you're
driving to work or you're on your lunch
break or you're winding down for the day
we're constantly seeing new research
about how many benefits there are to
meditation and simple habit is the
perfect way for beginners to get started
with meditation but it's also just as
useful for people who already meditate
and want a library of guided meditations
right at their fingertips the app also
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app I think almost
anyone could hugely benefit from an app
like this you can try it for free for a
week by going to simple habit calm slash
Pakman I've put a link underneath this
video